Je ne savais pas à quoi m'attendre
assis Je n'ai pas participé à la réalisation du
film Je ne l'ai pas réalisé Je ne l'ai pas écrit
Je ne suis qu'un fanboy Je suis dans le noir Le
cinéma démarre Les machines envoient un terminateur
retour à l'époque d'avant la guerre pour tuer
ma mère Sarah Connor et je commence à
voir des choses je reconnais que c'est très
respectueux des deux premiers films belle
nuit pour une promenade tes vêtements
me les donnent de temps
en temps tout d'un coup ça  juste des embardées
[Musique]
Je t'attendais et maintenant je
vais boire un verre J'ai l'impression que la
franchise a été revigorée comme si
c'était une Renaissance
si tu veux vivre tout a changé
si tu regardes pourquoi les films sont devenus des
classiques  ils avaient des personnages que vous
aimez le Terminator c'est agréable de vous rencontrer
j'ai essayé de lui apprendre à se
fondre je sais qu'il a besoin de travailler le nouveau film
que dans mon esprit je considère comme le troisième
film où nous voyons Arnold prendre le personnage
encore plus loin tout le monde répond à Sarah
Connor bien essayé
mais les femmes je thi  nk elle représente une sorte
d'autonomisation et pourtant il y a une
vulnérabilité là-bas parce que cette
force n'a pas de prix comment pouvez-vous
être ici nous sommes passés du premier film
The Terminator étant le pire dur à cuire de l'
histoire au deuxième film lui étant
presque un père  comprendre John l'idée de
prendre John Connor et de le retourner
au méchant qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait à mon
fils survivre était ce que tu m'as appris c'est
plutôt cool parce que tu as un riff contre toute
attente tout est question de torsion pas de
machine non mec tu aimes le  Terminator
films je reviendrai j'adore ce film